♪ ♪
>> Greg: THEY WANT TO CONTROL
HIS THINKING, BUT DAVE CHAPELLE
ISN'T BLINKING.
THE COMEDIAN STICKS TO HIS GUNS
BENDING FREE SPEECH, COMEDY, AND
FUN.
HE'S ADDRESSING THE PROTEST OVER
HIS NEW STAND-UP SPECIAL IN HIS
COMMENTS ABOUT THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S AFTER NETFLIX EMPLOYEES
STAGED A WALKOUT LAST WEEK WHICH
WAS ATTENDED BY TENS OF PEOPLE.
I'VE SEEN MORE PEOPLE IN
HAMMER'S HOT TUB.
PLUS A FEW ANIMALS.
IT'S BEEN SAID IN THE PRESS HE
HAS BEEN INVITED TO SPEAK TO THE
TRANSGENDER EMPLOYEES NETFLIX
AND HE REFUSED.
>> IT'S BEEN SAID IN THE PRESS
THAT I WAS INVITED TO SPEAK TO
TRANSGENDER EMPLOYEES OF NETFLIX
AND I REFUSED.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
IF THEY HAD INVITED ME, I WOULD
HAVE ACCEPTED IT, ALTHOUGH I AM
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT WE ARE
SPEAKING ABOUT.
I SAID WHAT I SAID AND BOY, I
HEARD WHAT YOU SAID TO.
MY GOD, HOW COULD I NOT
>> President Biden: YOU SAID
YOU WANT A SAFE WORKING
ENVIRONMENT, IT SEEMS LIKE I AM
THE ONLY ONE WHO CAN'T GO TO THE
OFFICE ANYMORE.
>> Greg: IF HE WALKED THEY
WOULD TREAT HIM LIKE AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER.
HE REVEALED HIS DOCUMENTARY HAS
BEEN EXPELLED FROM FILM
FESTIVALS.
>> THE FILM I MADE WAS INVITED
TO EVERY FILM FESTIVAL IN THE
UNITED STATES AND SOME OF THOSE
INVITATIONS I ACCEPTED TO.
WHEN THIS CONTROVERSY CAME OUT
ABOUT THE CLOSER, THEY BEGAN
THIS INVITING ME FROM THESE FILM
FESTIVALS.
AND NOW, TODAY, NOT A FILM
COMPANY, NOT A MOVIE STUDIO, NOT
A FILM FESTIVAL, NOBODY WILL
TOUCH THIS FILM.
THANK GOD FOR NETFLIX, HE'S THE
ONLY ONE WHO DIDN'T CANCEL ME
YET.
>> THEN HE SPOKE DIRECTLY TO THE
TRANS COMMUNITY, HE SAID IF HE
WANTS TO MEET WITH THEM HE'S
MORE THAN WILLING TO HE HAS SOME
CONDITIONS.
>> IF YOU WANT TO MEET WITH ME,
I WOULD BE MORE THAN WILLING TO.
BUT I HAVE SOME CONDITIONS.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU CANNOT COME IF
YOU HAVE NOT WATCHED MY SPECIAL
FROM BEGINNING TO END.
YOU MUST COME TO A PLACE OF MY
CHOOSING, AND A TIME OF MY
CHOOSING.
AND THIRD, YOU MUST ADMIT THAT
HANNAH GATSBY IS NOT FUNNY.
>> Greg: THAT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE.
SHE DENOUNCED THE NETFLIX
SPECIAL AND I'M TOLD SHE HAS A
FEW NETFLIX SPECIALS, THEY ARE
THE ONLY SPECIALS WITH A TRIGGER
WARNING THAT READS "WILL NOT
INDUCE LAUGHTER."
WAS THAT FAIR?
SHE IS NOT UNFUNNY, OR IS SHE?
>> WE'VE HEARD FROM PEOPLE WHO
CAN'T TAKE A JOKE, NOW WE'VE
HEARD FROM SOMEONE WHO CAN'T
TELL ONE.
WHEN HER SPECIAL CAME OUT, THEY
ACTUALLY TRIED TO SAY OH, NO,
THIS IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
COMEDY.
I HAD ALL THESE MESSAGES PEOPLE
WERE SENDING ME SAYING, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO GET LAUGHS,
COMEDY DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
ENTERTAINING.
FINALLY I HAD TO BLOCK JOE
MACKIE.
ONE MORE THING ABOUT THIS
NETFLIX PROTEST, THERE WERE SO
FEW PEOPLE THERE THEY WEREN'T
EVEN WORRIED ABOUT COVID RULES.
A DOZEN PEOPLE, YOU CAN TELL
BECAUSE THE CAMERAS -- ANY
CLOSER THOSE CAMERAS WOULD BE
PERFORMING A COLONOSCOPY.
DON'T FALL FOR WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING, THEY DON'T REPRESENT A
LARGE GROUP OF ANY PEOPLE, LET
ALONE THIS COMMUNITY THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Greg: WHENEVER YOU SEE ANY
NEWS STORIES WHERE THE CAMERA
CLOSE UP FOR A GROUP, THAT TELLS
YOU THERE IS NO GROUP.
TYRUS, IS THIS ALL PART OF A
BRILLIANT ROLLOUT OF HIS
SPECIAL?
HE TURNED HIS ADVERSARIES INTO
PUBLICISTS.
SO MANY PEOPLE KNOW MORE ABOUT
THIS THAN ANYBODY.
>> I WOULD THINK, MAYBE, BUT
CHAPPELLE IS ONE OF THOSE
BROTHER IS NOT DRIVEN BY MONEY
AND FAME, HE WALKED AWAY FROM
$50 MILLION AND I CAN'T SEE HIM
PUTTING HIMSELF THROUGH THIS,
HIS FAMILY THROUGH THIS JUST TO
GET YOU TO WATCH BECAUSE THEY
ARE GOING TO SHOW UP TO WATCH.
I THINK WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS
SOME OF US HAVE TO COME FORWARD,
I THINK IT'S TIME I CAME FORWARD
TO.
I WROTE THE JOKES, I'M SORRY.
THAT WAS ME, I CAN'T LET
CHAPPELLE TAKE ALL THE HEAT
ANYMORE, I DID THAT, COME GET
ME.
THEY GO AFTER HIM SO HARD AND
THEY PUSH SO HARD, THAT HE WAS
TRANSPHOBIC AND ATTACKING
PEOPLE, THEY TRY TO COMPARE IT
TO OTHER THINGS.
AND I FOR ONE WAS LIKE WHEN DO I
GET MY TURN TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
DAVE CHAPELLE?
ALL THE LIGHT-SKINNED BROTHER
JOKES MADE OVER THE YEARS, I WAS
TALKING ABOUT HOW HANDSOME WE
ARE AND WE GET THE JOBS AND THE
GIRLS, IT'S UNBELIEVABLY
UPSETTING.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY TIMES HE SAID
THE N-WORD ON TV?
BECAUSE HE'S BLACK, HE GETS A
PASS?
YOU GIVE ME MY PLATFORM SO WE
CAN GO AFTER HIM.
ANOTHER THING THAT IS REALLY
GREAT AND I WISH WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT A GROUP COMING AFTER YOU
AS PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING IT'S
CAUSING HATE.
ONE OF THE THINGS I ENJOY ABOUT
WHEN THEY HAD CLAN MEETINGS, AT
THE END OF EVERY MEETING THEY
TALKED ABOUT GETTING RID OF ALL
THE DASH FROM THE NEIGHBORHOOD,
IT WAS ABOUT SETTING UP A
SCHOLARSHIP FUND FOR MINORITY
CHILDREN, THAT'S WHAT DAVE
CHAPELLE DID TO THE WOMAN WHO
PASSED AWAY, HE GOT A
SCHOLARSHIP FOR HER CHILDREN.
THAT'S NORMALLY WHAT YOU DO WHEN
YOU WANT TO HATE A GROUP, YOU
PAY FOR THE KIDS TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
>> Greg: YOU WATCH THE
SPECIAL, THAT'S WHAT HE ENDS UP
DOING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I FEEL LIKE THE ONLY GOOD
THING ABOUT CHINESE CORONA, THE
PANDEMIC IS A LOT OF US WATCHED
A LOT OF TELEVISION.
ALL OF THESE CONTROVERSIES CAME
OUT ABOUT WHAT'S ON AND WHAT'S
NOT ON AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BEST TV SHOW OF ALL WAS OR
WHATEVER FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
HAD KIDS, WE GOT TO LISTEN TO
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
CLASSROOMS.
THAT'S WHY THIS FIRESTORM IS
GOING ON IN VIRGINIA.
I SAY TO DAVE CHAPELLE AND TO
YOU, IT'S NICE TO HAVE COMEDY
THAT IS FUNNY.
I THINK IF THE COUNTRY COULD
LAUGH A LITTLE BIT, MAYBE WE
WOULD GET BETTER.
>> Greg: HE'S GOT THE MONEY,
WHAT HE'S DOING IS WHAT
JERRY SEINFELD SHOULD HAVE DONE,
OTHER PEOPLE WITH HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS, HE'S DOING IT TO
PROTECT PEOPLE WHO COULD BE
CANCELED OR DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
OR THE WILL.
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE HAVING MONEY
AND NEVER SAYING [BLEEP].
>> Greg: YOU JUST SAID IT
TWICE AND YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
MONEY.
>> I DON'T HAVE THAT MONEY.
>> YOU MUST HAVE F YOU MONEY IF
YOU ARE GOING TO SAY F YOU.
>> HE'S ONLY GOING TO MEET WITH
CERTAIN TRANS PEOPLE, YOU MEAN
HE'S TREATING TRANS PEOPLE LIKE
INDIVIDUALS?
HE'S SAYING THE SAME THING, I
WOULD HAVE TRANS FRIENDS IF THEY
ARE FUNNY PEOPLE BUT WE DO THAT
ALL THE TIME WITH EACH OTHER.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO TREAT OTHER
PEOPLE AS INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS
OF GENDER, RACE, ISN'T THAT WHAT
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING?
>> Greg: THIS IS GOING TO BE
THE TOPIC OF OUR NEXT BLOCK, THE
IDEA THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
IDENTITY BLOCK, IT'S ABOUT WHO
ARE THE JERKS VERSUS THE
NONJERKS, THAT'S HOW WE SHOULD
BE SEGREGATING.
WE SHOULD BE SEGREGATING THE
JERKS.
>> I LIKE IT TO.
>> Greg: U